[Music]
hello my name is ismael yuste and I'm a
strategic cloud engineer at google cloud
today I'm going to talk about how to make
reports in the cloud with data studio
google data studio is designed for
business analysts it generates
beautiful reports that can be shared in the
In the same way as the drive documents,
to create these reports,
technical knowledge is not necessary, but
if knowledge of the data that we are going to
present and connects, as in everything in the
google cloud, with the various
google data sources, it will already be the bit query
adwords  youtube anyone who
can think of
how data studio works well first
we connect our data by adding
any data source any data
set for example a bit query to which
we have access with our
credentials then we generate the
report and define the types of
graphic tables or mergers of  data that
we want to show and finally we
share this report with our
collaborators or with our  In our organization,
as you can see, we can connect with
various data sources from files
that we upload to the tool to data from the
Google ecosystem, such as
Adwords or different cloud tools such
as bit query, cloud sql, or even
Google spreadsheets, we have to
authorize the  access once
the source is selected and with that we already have access to
the
information regarding collaboration data study
will work just like
drive documents we will be able to make
changes to the document and
our collaborators will be able to
see them in real time  or we are going to be able to be
working on different pages of
our report with different
collaborators to generate a report
very quickly
as an example of a report here we can see
an example of a public
adwords report with the possibility of viewing
data about our website as cost  per
click and to filter by temporary space or to
understand how our
adwords campaigns at a glance and we are
going to see it here we can see the report
in data studio as you can see it is an example
I had told you that we can filter by
time space in this case it is
filtered by the last 30 days we are
going to tell it to filter us  for the
last 15 days, it will make a query
on the data source filtering for
only those 15 days and we will be able to
see here the evolution of our cost per
click, for example, the conversions, the
average cost per click, etc.,
etc.,
and even see some  information in
tabular mode such as the
most important campaigns of our
demo environment or distribution by
devices, whether mobile or
computer, we have seen how we can
access data studio, how we can
generate a data source to create
our own reports and how to
share those  reports with our
collaborators I encourage you to start
using data studio at data studio
dot google.com from there many
thanks  thank you
no